LAURA LING: Growing up,
you were African American,
socialized as a girl,
adopted by a white family.
That must have been
extremely confusing for you.
KINGSTON FARADY: It was
really, really hard.
And there was a
lot of questioning
around how did I get here, and
who am I, and how do I do this.
I always felt--
or not even felt,
I knew that I was different.
It made me very quiet
and introverted and sad.
I remember in my childhood
just always thinking
this isn't going to be my life.
LAURA LING: When you
finally come to the decision
to transition?
KINGSTON FARADY: I started
thinking about transitioning
around 17, 18 years old.
So it was around
that time that I
started to ask myself questions
around could this be me.
Am I really a man
that had been assigned
at birth the wrong gender.
I finally made the decision
when I was about 25.
I still remember receiving
my first testosterone shot,
and how happy I was.
I knew I made the
right decision.
LAURA LING: What was it
like the first few years
after you transitioned?
KINGSTON FARADY:
They were tough.
They were very hard.
So much shifted quickly.
You're learning new emotions.
You're learning how to
deal with new thoughts.
deal with a changing body.
And then on top of that,
you're engaging with the world
in a brand-new way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Tell
me about the ritual
that you have adopted to help
you in this life's journey.
KINGSTON FARADY: There are
so many different aspects
of a human being.
Mind, body, spirit, will.
And for me, transitioning,
I had to figure out
who am I now in terms of these
different aspects of my being.
And so I created Love
Your Vehicle, your vehicle
being your body, your temple.
I created that
physical routine that I
needed to build my body into
what I wanted it to look like.
And I love trail run,
I love the obstacle
of having to leap
over roots of trees
and run up hills and feel
dirt and breathe the air.
The mind component
is about learning.
It's critical that every
single day I spend time
really enriching my
understanding of what's
happening around me.
And the spiritual component
is about meditation.
When I meditate, I
will really focus
on just keeping my mind calm.
And I get to
experience that peace
and realize that there is a
peace that is a part of life
that we can have.
LAURA LING: How has
this ritual of yours
of loving your vehicle
changed you as a person?
KINGSTON FARADY: It has
made me a lot stronger.
And it's also allowed
me to be OK with myself
as a transgender person.
It's allowed me--
it's helped me to walk
in the world with strength
and pride and confidence.
And it's allowed me to believe
that not only are transgender
people real, but
we are important,
and we are a part of
the fabric of life,
despite anything else that
I might hear during the day.
LAURA LING: Be sure to
watch this next episode.
When you look in the mirror now,
who's the person that you see?
SPEAKER 3: So I see a lot
more confident person.
I see someone who's
made a lot of progress.
And most of all, I see
someone who's on a journey.